SCIENCE TO ME IS
THE ABSOLUTE COOLEST THING EVER.
NOT TO GET, LIKE,
HIPPY-DIPPY ABOUT IT,
BUT SCIENCE IS EVERYWHERE.
SO ANYTHING THAT'S COOL
IS SCIENCE.
LIKE PANTS -- THAT'S SCIENCE.
IT'S WHAT WE'RE MADE OF.
AND WITHOUT SCIENCE,
WE HAVE NOTHING.
IT'S MORE THAN JUST INFORMATION.
IT'S MORE THAN JUST
WHAT YOU READ IN A TEXTBOOK.
SCIENCE ITSELF IS A PROCESS.
IT'S A MEANS BY WHICH WE
INTERROGATE THE NATURAL WORLD.
SCIENCE HELPS US UNDERSTAND
THE WHO, WHAT, WHERE, WHEN,
WHY, AND HOW OF THE UNIVERSE.
IT'S COMPLETELY IMPARTIAL.
IT'S ALWAYS READY
TO BE PROVEN INCORRECT
IF NEW, BETTER INFORMATION
COMES IN.
TO ME,
SCIENCE IS THE ULTIMATE COOL.
IT'S CREATING SOMETHING
THAT NEVER EXISTED BEFORE,
AND I THINK THAT SOME
OF THE WORK THAT I'VE DONE --
EVEN WORK THAT I DID
30 YEARS AGO --
IF I HADN'T DONE IT
AT THAT TIME,
IT STILL WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN KNOWN TO THIS DAY.
YOU REALLY GET DOWN
TO THE BONES OF IT,
SCIENCE IS ULTIMATELY
WHO WE ARE.
EVERYTHING THAT'S COOL
IS SCIENCE, SO SCIENCE IS COOL.
THERE'S AN EQUATION IN THERE
SOMEWHERE, I'M SURE.
[ CHUCKLES ]